lights huh hi
lily don't kill me please
among us is a video game that has taken
the world by storm
it's one of the most watched games on
twitch
and youtube even politicians are playing
it
[Music]
sorry but what if
instead of this game happening on our
computer
screens it happened in real life
which crewmates would be sus
what sort of tasks do you need to do
[Music]
and could you survive until the end
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if among us happened in real life
game begin for the uninitiated
here's how among us works the game can
have
up to 10 players the majority of them
are known as crewmates
they spend their time trying to fix
their failing spaceship
the rest are imposters or aliens
their goal is to stop the crewmates from
repairing the ship
by any means necessary that includes
deception murder or just being really
annoying
[Music]
the trick here is that the majority of
the game
is played without being able to
communicate with the other players
the only time you're able to talk is
when a meeting is called
there you can discuss who you think the
imposter might be and
shove them out of the airlock
if the imposter is a really good liar
you're gonna have a tough time
but if the crewmates manage to eject the
imposters
before it's too late then they win the
game
oh and don't forget anyone who's killed
can always come back as a ghost
now that we know more about how among us
works
what would happen if it took place in
real life
[Music]
well for this scenario naturally we're
going to have it
take place on a spaceship and what
better spaceship than
the international space station
you and nine other crewmates are on
board
you have to complete tasks on the ship
or everything goes wrong
the only problem here is that three of
your other crewmates
are frequently aliens
they are gonna do everything they can to
prevent you from getting your job
done issues on the iss are pretty common
and
crew members often have to work together
to repair them
on september 28 2020 three
iss members were woken by mission
control after
it was reported there was a leak on the
ship
the three crew members all had to work
together to identify the leak
and then repair it this was an
ongoing problem first discovered more
than a year earlier
the crew had spent several weeks
figuring out where the leak was coming
from
so unlike among us your tasks here
wouldn't be
simple mini-games where you're
connecting wires or
destroying asteroids this would require
teamwork and some intricate mechanical
engineering
and just like the game let's assume
you're wearing a spacesuit
and you're unable to communicate with
your crew
now you're performing an incredibly
complicated task
one that requires multiple people and
you're
unable to talk to anyone what could
possibly go wrong
well now that your crew is distracted by
all these complex tasks
this would be the perfect opportunity
for the imposters
to cause some trouble now you wouldn't
know exactly what they're doing but that
oh a dead body has been reported
and of course it was inelectrical
it's always electrical now
you could take off your spacesuit and
talk to your crew
who is the imposter
[Music]
you saw that one guy who went toward
electrical but
then you could have sworn he was helping
you with the task
you were near the one dressed in blue
for a bit but
he didn't seem to do anything strange
hm could it be
but wait as you've been thinking during
this time
the entire crew has decided that you
must be the imposter
i guess that's what you get for being so
quiet
they've all cast their votes and now
you've been ejected
into space instead of getting
a harmless game over scene this
would mean imminent death for you
as soon as you're kicked out of the ship
your lungs would expand and
burst due to the loss of external
pressure
your skin would balloon up from the
water in your body
you'd also get a nasty sunburn from the
radiation and
then suffocate to death maybe if you had
just
told the crewmates what you were doing
you would have had a better chance
well now that you're a ghost and can get
a better sense of what's going on you
see that you were right it was the blue
guy
and now he's wiping out the rest of your
crew
oh no and after
all of your crew is gone the iss
would then be completely destroyed
let's hope that if aliens are among us
that they're pretty obvious and we don't
have to worry about anyone
being suss or not to learn more
about among us check out this week's
what if discussed podcast
we learned the ins and outs of the game
tips and tricks with leanna rupert of
game informer
check it out